SPIRIT AND THEN I WATCHED ALL OF
THE CANDIDATES, AND I JUST
THOUGHT TO MYSELF, DONALD TRUMPW
THOUGHT TO MYSELF, DONALD TRUMPU
THOUGHT TO MYSELF, DONALD TRUMPD
EAT THEM UP.
I GAVE 100% OF THE MONEY AWAY,
WHAT'S WRONG WITH THAT?
AND I TURN AND THEY ARE
CRITICIZING ME FOR IT.
ASK THEM WHAT THEY ARE DOING,
WHY DID THEY NOT DO THAT?
THEY HAD A CHANCE TO MAKE A LOT
OF MONEY AND HOW MUCH OF THEIR
OWN MONEY DID THEY PUT INTO THE
CAMPAIGN?
>> Martha: AFTER THE FIRE
EXCHANGE WITH A MAN AT A
TOWN HALL, JOE BIDEN IS PICKING
A NEW FIGHT.
WATCH THIS.
>> YOU GUYS GOT IT ALL WRONG
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED.
IT IS JUST BAD JUDGMENT.
YOU ALL THOUGHT THAT WHAT
HAPPENED WAS THE PARTY MOVED
EXTREMELY TO THE LEFT AFTER
HILLARY.
AOC WAS THE NEW PARTY.
SHE IS A BRIGHT AND WONDERFUL
PERSON, BUT WHERE'S THE PARTY?
COME ON, MAN.
>> Martha: COME ON, MAN, COME
ON, JESSE.
THIS IS A FEISTY YEAR JOE BIDEN,
FIGHTING BACK AT THE 2020
CANDIDATES PRIOR TO SAYING COME
ON, MAN.
WHAT DID YOU SAY?
GET YOUR FACTS STRAIGHT, JACK.
>> Jesse: ONLY HUNTER HAD A
MORE LIVELY WEEK THAN JOE.
BIDEN TRIES TO CONVINCE
EVERYBODY WHEN HE IS HAS COME ON
MAN, LIKE THAT IT'S GOING
EXPLAIN EVERYTHING.
IS THAT IT?
BUT HERE'S THE THING THAT HE IS
WRONG ABOUT SO MANY THINGS, BUT
HE IS RIGHT ABOUT THIS.
TWITTER IS NOT WHERE REGULAR
AMERICANS ARE, ESPECIALLY WHERE
DEMOCRATS, BLACK, BROWN, WITH
FAMILIES, WITH JOBS, THEY WANT
TO KEEP THEIR HEALTH CARE.
THEY WANT TO KEEP THEIR SUV.
THEY WANT TO KEEP THEIR MONEY.
THESE PEOPLE DON'T UNDERSTAND
THAT AND THEY THROW PEOPLE LIKE
AOC, THE SQUAD, THE GREEN NEW
DEAL, LIZ WARREN.
THEY WANT TO REVOLUTIONIZE
AMERICA.
THEY ARE NOT WITH THAT CROWD.
THAT IS PRETTY OBVIOUS EVEN TO
SLEEPY JOE.
>> Juan: I WANT TO SAY THIS TO
AFFIRM WHAT YOU JUST SAID, THE
FACT THAT HE IS IN THE LEAD AS
THOUGH CENTRIST IS EVIDENCE THAT
THE LEFT IS NOT DOMINATING EVEN
AMONG THE DEMOCRATS.
SO THERE IS A RISE IN THE
NUMBERS WHO ARE SELF IDENTIFYING
AS LIBERALS, BUT IT IS STILL THE
CASE THAT MOST DEMOCRATS SELF
IDENTIFY AS EITHER MODERATE OR
CONSERVATIVE DEMOCRATS.
>> Martha: WHAT ABOUT
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG, THE FEELING
WAS IF JOE BIDEN WAS IN THE
RACE, THERE WOULD NOT BE ROOM
FOR MICHAEL BLOOMBERG OR A
MR. STARBUCKS, HOWARD SCHULTZ,
THANK YOU.
SO DO YOU THINK THERE IS NOW?
AND DO YOU THINK PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING FOR THAT ALTERNATIVE TO
JOE BIDEN?
>> Juan: THE THING IS THAT
JOE BIDEN HAS NOT FADED.
SO THE ARGUMENT WOULD BE FOR
BLOOMBERG, I AM ELECTABLE, I CAN
BEAT TRUMP.
AND HE MAY BE A VERY GOOD
CANDIDATE IF IT IS BLOOMBERG
VERSUS TRUMP, BUT HE HAS TO GET
THROUGH THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY,
HE NEEDS A LANE.
AND AT THE MOMENT THE LANE IS
OCCUPIED AND SUCCESSFULLY SO BY
JOE BIDEN.
THE QUESTION FOR MR. BLOOMBERG
IS HOW DO YOU SAY TO VOTERS, OH,
YEAH, I AM BETTER FOR YOU THAN
JOE BIDEN?
>> Jesse: BUT, JUAN, HE IS
ONLY AT 19% NATIONALLY.
BIDEN IS ONLY A 19%.
>> Juan: THAT IS FINE.
>> Jesse: THAT IS EASY
PICKENS.
>> Martha: AND BLOOMBERG IS
GAINING TRACTION, NOWHERE TO GO
BUT UP.
>> Greg: PRETTY CLOSE TO
TRACTION AT THAT AGE.
THEY ARE THE PARTY OF GRUMPY OLD
MEN.
AND YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
THIS.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE
CANDIDATES.
THIS IS ABOUT TRUMP PIT HE IS
NOT THAT MUCH DIFFERENT IN AGE,
BUT IT IS OBVIOUS IN TERMS OF
ENERGY AND SPIRIT, THERE IS A
GULP.
TRUMP IS NOT MUCH YOUNGER, BUT
HE HAS A DINER CUP OF COFFEE, A
BOTTOMLESS, BOTTOMLESS ENERGY.
I WAS GOING TO SAY SOMETHING
ELSE, BUT I STOP.
IF YOU COMPARE PEOPLE HIS AGE,
LOOK WHAT HE DID TO ROBERT
DE NIRO.
HE TURNED HIM INTO A SPUTTERING
JACKASS.
PRETENDING THAT HE IS CLINT
EASTWOOD IN "GRAND TORINO."
HE IS SCROOGE MEANT DOC AND
PANTS.
I DON'T SEE HOW ANYBODY WILL
STAND UP AND ENERGY.
>> Jesse: THEY WILL JUST
CHALLENGE HIM TO A PUSH-UP
CONTEST.
>> Martha: WHAT IT IS WITH
THAT JOKE.
>> Martha: TAKEN BEHIND THE
BARN OR WE WILL HAVE A PUSH-UP
CONTEST.
EMILY --
>> Jesse: PLEASE DON'T DO
THAT.
A >> Martha: WHAT ABOUT
MEDICARE FOR ALL, THAT MAY BE
THE HILL TO DIE ON FOR SOME OF
THESE CANDIDATES, BECAUSE IT
LOOKS LIKE IT IS VERY
PROBLEMATIC, AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT WILL HELP MICHAEL BLOOMBERG
AS HE MOVES FORWARD AND PERHAPS
BIDEN.
>> Emily: WHAT IS INTERESTING
AS A LOT OF THE MESSAGING THAT
WE JUST SAW HER EARLIER IS ABOUT
THE DEMOCRATIC FIELD, THAT'S WHY
THEY ARE TERRIBLE, BUT NOT QUITE
YET WHY HE IS OFF.
AS YOU ARE POINTING OUT.
AND CONTRAST WITH THE LOOMING
RECESSION WITH OBAMA'S MESSAGE
HOPE AND CHANGE, AND HALF OF THE
COUNTRY ROLLED THEIR EYES, BUT
IT RESONATED CLEARLY AND
ESPECIALLY TO THE DEMOCRATS.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHY
MAYOR PETE IS SURGING AND
RESONATING IN OHIO AND IOWA AND
NEW HAMPSHIRE, BECAUSE OF THE
POSITIVE SPIN.
BUT IF HE WINS THE PRIMARY, HE
WILL HAVE TO THREAD THE NEEDLE,
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY ONCE WE GET
PAST THE PRIMARIES, THE QUESTION
IS TRUMP OR A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION.
BUT THEY HAVE TO BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE POSITIVE.
>> Martha: YOU CANNOT WIN WITH
THAT, YOU CANNOT BE IN AN
INCUMBENT WITH THAT POSITIVE
MESSAGE THAT GALVANIZES VOTERS
AND MAKES THEM DRAWN TO YOU,
OKAY, COMING UP NEXT, A LIBERAL
CITY UNDER FIRE OVER A PROGRAM
THAT RELOCATES.
♪ ♪
Do you have concerns about mild
memory loss related to aging?